bonjour à tous l'objectif c'est de vous
présenter les sept priorités qui seront
celles du prochain mandat est juste un
mois avant
ce sur quoi j'ai veillé sur le mandat
qui vient de s'achever c'est que ce
qu'on avait dit soient tenus on l'a fait
par exemple sur les économies de
fonctionnement de la région sur les
mesures qu'on a prises pour sécuriser
nos lycées à chaque fois ce que j'ai
voulu c'est que ce qu'on avait promis ce
sur quoi on s'était engagés soit tenue
la deuxième chose qui est très
importante pour moi c'est que j'aime que
les choses soient claires et que ça
corresponde sur les mesures qu'on
propose sur des convictions parfois que
j'ai défendues depuis longtemps en
politique on a beaucoup de girouette
moi j'aime bien accueilli et de la
constance dans les valeurs qu'on défend
et j'espère que vous allez retrouver sur
nos sept priorités
la première d'abord pour nous c'est la
sécurité déjà il ya cinq ans on avait
oeuvré dessus notamment sur la
sécurisation du luth des lycées on va
continuer constituer des brigades
régionales de sécurité pour protéger nos
lycées utiliser les caméras avec
reconnaissance faciale pour lutter
contre les terroristes
voir aussi protéger nos enfants quand
ils sont dans les transports scolaires
contre le racket et de harcèlement et
puis enfin très important supprimer
l'accès aux aides de la région pour les
délinquants multirécidivistes
dans notre pays on a un problème énorme
il n'y a jamais de sanctions
les gens qui ne respectent pas les
règles de la république et qui ensuite
profit de la république
le deuxième domaine c'est la santé avec
pour nous le fait de décider de se bat
pour accéder à la santé dans des
territoires où on manque de médecins
nous allons avec les communes salariés
des médecins sur des territoires où il
n'ya pas de généralistes depuis des
années et aujourd'hui c'est la seule
solution
et puis organiser aussi des
consultations mobile de spécialistes
avaient rendez vous avec un dermato avec
un pédiatre avec un ophtalmo c'est un
vrai parcours du combattant
l'objectif pour nous c'est que rompuy
organisé ces consultations directement
sur les terribles
troisième priorité on veut coupler ça
avec la mise en place d'une mutuelle
régionale de santé notamment pour les
classes moyennes et en ciblant de façon
prioritaire un certain nombre de nos
retraités qui n'ont pas de mutuelle
aujourd'hui où des étudiants qui n'ont
pas accès à la mutuelle quatrième point
ramener les emplois sur le territoire il
ya cinq ans on avait travaillé sur une
préférence régionale donner la priorité
à ce qui était produit dans notre région
là je veux qu'on aille plus loin avec un
plan pour relocaliser doté d'un milliard
d'euros la constitution d'un fonds
souverain pour pouvoir aider en priorité
nos pme et ramener la production qui
partit en asie dans les pays de l'est
sur notre territoire
on a plein de projets en la matière et
là on peut vraiment parvenir à avancer
et abouti cinquième point la qualité de
l'air qui est un domaine aujourd'hui qui
est extrêmement important on veut en
faire la grande cause régionale c'est un
sujet de santé c'est un sujet
d'environnement c'est un sujet de
qualité vie en travaillant à la fois sur
les mobilités les isolations énergétique
diminuer la pollution sixième point nos
jeunes nos étudiants certains plaident
pour un rsa jeunes moi j ai jamais cru
on veut au contraire mettre en place un
pass réussite pour proposer à nos
étudiants d accompagnement quand ils
vont sur des métiers qui recrutent et
qui sont aux tensions et métiers de
l'industrie
les métiers du digital les métiers du
service à la personne et puis le
septième celui qui tient très à coeur et
vous savez que quand je le dis on tient
parole nous il n'y a aucune augmentation
d'impôts ou de taxes sur les familles de
l'impression notre région a été la mieux
gérée de france étude qui a été menée
par agnès verdier molinié
on n'a laissé aucune aide supplémentaire
à nos enfants aucune de ces promesses ne
sera financée par des augmentations
d'impôts ou par des augmentations d'être
une région solide pour tourner la page
de la crise aussi avec des idées qui
peuvent nous inspirer tous dans ce qu'on
veut à l'avenir pour notre pays mais
pour ça j'ai besoin de vous et j'ai
besoin de vous nous fassiez confiance le
20 juin